I when I think of Rich Homie Quan I
think of like uh
I just think that it's so hard for you
to make bad music because you're so good
at this [ __ ] and I'm glad just to know
that you're independent now because I
feel like when you're in a position like
you where everyone might be looking at
you like man quantity had none for a
minute you kind of want to be in an
independent space because you could just
shoot as many shots as you want because
you know if something's gonna go in yeah
because you're rich homie Quan and you
do this [ __ ] bro
I think the break was necessary was
needed though man you know what I'm
saying because it was at a time like
well I was a big headed bro and I can
admit that you know what I'm saying wow
um I was on my high horse he fit me like
and I take accountability for that so
the break was really needy it wasn't
really about uh
me taking a break because the break
wasn't like I oh I'm gonna chill like I
was forced to take it and with me taking
a break
oh man I had to find you know they had
to face the man in the mirror man you
know and put something blame on myself
yeah